here's what would happen if we detonated
a new on the moon
well the short answer is this
it wouldn't affect Humanity at all if we
detonated a nuke on the moon well
probably the most damage we do
physically is to add another crater to
its surface which is ironic since the
moon gets its craters from blocking
meteorites heading for earth so maybe we
should stop trying to attack it and be
grateful for its defenses and the
seasons and the tides now if we used a
bigger bomb roughly 10 trillion Mega
tons of TMT bigger well then an
explosion of that size would likely push
the moon out of Earth's orbit this would
expose us to meteors affect our Tides
eventually killing all marine life while
catastrophically affecting our Seasons
so